Barry
Barry, Barry
it’s really you
surprise!
Happy Birthday
Oliver would have wanted you to have this.
It's hard to believe it's been three years
everybody stopped drinking.
Iris The last time I encountered
Team Flash, I learned what was coming.
A crisis to end the multiverse.
I guess it didn't take.
Barry Barry Barry
What have you done this time?
It's really you.
Okay, let's go.
Barry, let go.
It's not just your world. That’s in danger.
There's a new multiverse
to replace the one that had fallen
No one has to watch their loved ones die.
Everyone has darkness inside them.
You be a guiding light.
A hero
Are you ready to keep running?
Welcome back everyone
it's Charlie
This is be my new flash trailer.
Green Arrow Oliver Queen is back.
There's a whole bunch of Easter eggs
and references
to their previous crossovers,
so we'll break it all down.
If you're brand new to the channel, be
sure to subscribe to get all the videos.
We're
getting a whole bunch of trailers like
we just got the brand new Blue
Beetle trailer.
We'll get more flash
movie trailers really soon.
I know everybody is hoping to see
Grant Gustin cameo in the Flash movie,
Just Paying Off the Crisis
on Infinite Earths crossover
with Ezra miller's movie Flash.
In fact,
during the trailer, they reference Crisis
on Infinite Earths several times.
Of course, they open the trailer
with flash hugging Oliver Queen and him
joking about what he's done.
Now it's a callback
to their previous crossovers
when he said the same thing
a couple of different times.
What have you
done this time?
Oh, very.
What have you done this time?
That's meant to be a callback
to one of the original flash memes,
which in previous crossovers,
they had been making fun of that time too,
I believe.
Originally it was meant to be a joke about
Flashpoint like Sure is a nice timeline.
Be ashamed of someone, mess it up
every time everyone thinks of flash memes
now they just think about the Oliver Queen
grave meme with him pointing at it.
But one of the other jokes of the episode
is that the title is It's My Party
All Die If I Want To.
So this is Joke about the Flash dying
in order to go see Oliver Queen
because he's literally in purgatory
right now on Leandra in all these scenes
when they're meeting each other again
for the first time.
If you don't remember the Leon you island
name directly translates to purgatory.
So originally on the Arrow series,
when Oliver Queen
got stuck on the island in the pilot,
he got stuck on purgatory
like he died metaphorically,
and it was reborn as the Green Arrow.
But now it's more of a literal thing
because in Crisis on Infinite Earths,
he actually died in travel
to the cosmic version of purgatory
in the Arrowverse multiverse.
And it's represented by Keanu.
So this isn't the actual Leon you that
he's like he actually had to die
in order to talk to Oliver Queen.
Stephen Amell has also joked about this
a lot in real life too.
Like Oliver Queen died. He's
finally having some peace.
He's finally enjoying himself.
And now Flash has come along to bother him
and he's kind of joking like Barry,
Barry, Barry,
what have you done this time?
The other joke here too,
is when Barry hugs him for too long
and it starts to get kind of awkward,
he's like, Stop Hugging Me
is also a callback to previous crossovers.
What? He said the same
thing as well. Hey, let's go.
Very let go.
I am fast enough to just hug you without
you knowing, so you might as well
let me
try hug it out.
No, no.
And I really mean this time. Twice.
He's made me hug, you know?
All right. Hey, I mean it.
This is what the empty drinks of the bar
also represent.
There are
a bunch of different types of moments
referencing their previous crossovers.
Now, the way they cut the trailer,
they jump around
in the timeline of the episode
quite a bit.
Like you see Kid Flash, Wally West
come back and you see the blood work
feeling come back.
So it sounds like what's happening
in the episode in the regular world,
like before he goes to see Oliver Queen
before he dies and goes to see Oliver
Queen, the Sendhil Ramamurthy blood work
character returns and takes over.
Pretty much everybody.
And then he goes to Oliver Queen for help
after he seemingly dies, quote
unquote, like, Oh crap, I'm dead.
Wait a minute. Oliver Queen is dead.
I can go get his help because he's still
the specter and has all those powers.
I wasn't expecting
Wally West to come back for this episode,
but we knew he was coming back
this season at some point.
Been a hot minute
since he's been on the show.
They begin the episode sort of setting up
the whole concept of the title.
It's my Party, I'll Die if I want to
when they throw a party for The Flash.
Wally West is there, Diggle
is there in Diggle brings him Oliver
Queen's Bow because Oliver wanted him
to have it later.
When Oliver Queen comes
back to the world of the living,
you see him grab his bow again.
This is meant to be his original bow
from the pilot.
He had a bunch of different ones
that he used throughout the series,
but they want there
to be a lot of references
to all of their major crossovers,
like Crisis on Infinite Earths.
The other previous crossovers
between Aaron Flash
and to their original crossover
in the Flash pilot like the big pep talk
that he gives to Barry, like the pep talk
he gave him in the pilot episode.
If you don't remember,
the Flash character debuted on Arrow
in a two part crossover.
That's why the Arrowverse
is called the Arrowverse,
because it all started with the Arrow
Show.
Note that Diggle also changed
the timeline.
It's been three years
since Crisis on Infinite Earths.
When Oliver died, it seems like whatever
blood work is doing when he comes back,
he poisons Team Flash and that's
how he takes over most of their bodies.
He starts talking to Flash about how
he predicted crisis on infinite Earths.
When he jokes about it not sticking.
That's just another joke about Oliver
Queen creating a new multiverse
like rebirthing.
The multiverse,
which Oliver Queen talks to Barry about,
kind of explaining what actually did
happen during Crisis on Infinite Earths.
So it sounds like the Flash didn't
totally understand what happened
after everybody came back in the last part
of crisis on Infinite Earths.
If you remember,
one of the biggest changes
that they made in that final episode was
that in the new version of the multiverse,
they changed the earth and everyone was on
so that most of the characters,
not everybody,
but most of the characters were always
supposed to have been on Earth Prime
But mostly
what wound up happening, like in practice,
because they changed some things
even later on,
is that in the new timeline,
Supergirl had been on the same Arrowverse
Earth this whole time.
But for instance, the Titans,
the Green Lantern characters
from the Ryan Reynolds
Green Lantern movie in the Tyler
Hoechlin Superman were all on different
Earths now, as in the new timeline.
So originally Tyler Hoechlin
Superman had been in the arrowverse,
but in the new Superman Lois Show,
when they set that up
at the end of Crisis on Infinite Earths,
they put him on a different earth.
That's how they wound up changing things,
that he wound up having two sons
instead of the one son.
How they wound up aging them up so fast,
like they just had Diggle on Superman
Lois last season.
But because it's meant to take place
on a different Earth,
it was a completely
different version of Diggle, not the one
who briefly had the Green Lantern ring.
So even though they want a crisis
to put everybody
on the same earth in practice, it ended up
being way more messy after the fact.
You may have seen the Twitter threads that
a lot of the producers of the Arrowverse
were posting recently about how James
Gunn is rebooting everything,
and most of them were not invited
to help plan the new DC Universe.
They were kind of salty about that.
And it seems like
what happens during the episode
is that the Flash is able to yank
Oliver Queen
back to the world of the living,
or he uses his specter powers to do that
briefly.
They team up against bloodwork
like you see Diggle here with them,
so either he doesn't get affected
or they wind up fixing him.
First.
They team up against blood work
and defeat him.
And at the end of the episode
he gives Barry
another pep talk to the classic Oliver
Queen pep talk
and goes back to being dead,
paying off the title of the episode again.
It's my party. I'll die if I want to.
Like it's also Oliver Queen's Party
and he wants some peace,
so like he doesn't want to stick around.
Another quick reminder,
this is going to be episode nine
and there are only 13
episodes in the final season.
So like they are entering the final arc
of episodes they haven't confirmed.
Grant
Gustin will crossover in the Flash movie.
I think they're holding
that pretty close to the vest.
I'm hoping that he has a small cameo,
don't really care what he does
as long as it's a very brief cameo scene.
Also hoping for a John Wesley Shipp
cameo scene to the way
Grant Gustin talked about it
in a recent interview.
Though when The Flash in Season nine,
like when they have their series finale,
that will be
the official end of the arrowverse
And he said that he kind of enjoyed
that idea
that it's ending within
the Arrowverse is ending with them,
but they did change their plans for
the original ultimate ending for the show.
Originally, Grant Gustin
actually supported my theory,
like early on in
like the first season of The Flash.
My theory was
they should end the show with him dying
and becoming the bolt of lightning
that originally gave him powers.
It's a twist from the classic comics.
But here's the thing,
Grant Gustin said for a long time,
that's the ending that he wanted
for the character.
They wanted to kill them off
like they killed Oliver
Queen off at the end of Arrow.
But when the new showrunner took over,
when they were planning this final season,
they decided they wanted to keep Grant
Gaston's character alive.
So The Flash will not die
or he's not supposed to die
at the end of this series finale.
Not sure how I feel about that now.
We'll see after the final episode.
I'll probably do like another episode
after the finale.
But the other big reminders that James
Gunn is basically rebooting everything.
For the most part,
some characters will continue,
but it's meant to
be a completely new timeline in his DCU,
as they're calling it now.
Like it's
rebooting from the DCU into the DCU.
Everything will be connected
going forward.
Like all the big TV shows,
the HBO shows that they're doing now,
kind of like the Disney
Plus Marvel shows or connected to the MCU.
There are a few exceptions,
like the Robert Pattinson
version of the Batman, the Joaquin
Phenix Joker and other one offs.
Those will be called Elseworlds.
Like they'll be officially canonized
as Elseworlds.
But for the most part, all the new shows,
including the animated shows
and some of the video game stuff,
some of the video game stuff
will all be connected
to all the new movies.
A really good
example is the Blue Beetle character.
Originally that was supposed
to be completely different
from James Gunn's name,
but the way they designed the movie
didn't break the timeline.
Like even though they mentioned Batman
and some of the other Justice
League characters,
because it doesn't break
the brand new timeline, it's easier
for them to include that in the new DCU,
even though technically
the first official planned movie
as part of the DCU
is the Superman Legacy movie.
We don't have any announcements
about that,
about casting yet,
about this new version of Superman.
When we do, of course,
I'll do more videos about it,
but post all of your reactions
to Oliver Queen coming back.
I know everybody's wondering now,
are there going to be any Arrowverse
cameos in the New DCU?
That would be crazy
if some of these characters do
cameo in some multiverse
kind of way in the future.
There's a bunch of stuff coming up.
Star Wars celebration is this weekend.
We might get an associate trailer.
I'll do videos for whatever
they wind up releasing.
Make sure you enable alerts for my channel
so you don't miss that.
Everyone click here for that
brand new Blue Beetle trailer video
and Easter eggs in.
Click here
for all my Mandalorian episodes.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe.
I'll see you guys in the next one.